I'm Gabriella farfan curator of gems and
minerals at the Smithsonian let's answer
some questions from the internet this is
Gem
[Music]
support at oep asks I have a really dumb
question that I'm too scared to ask in
class what's the difference between
rocks and minerals there's nothing in a
rock that is not a mineral rocks are
actually made up of minerals this is
called Granite if you look closely at
this rock you'll notice that it has
grains of different colors these are
individual crystals of different
minerals contained in this Granite are
the mineral quartz the mineral Feld Spar
and the mineral biotite and musite which
is also known as micia all minerals are
crystals by definition in this case this
mineral is called quartz what is a gem a
gem stone is a mineral crystal that has
been cut and faceted by an artist so
this would be the natural shape of a
crystal and it can eventually be cut and
Polished into a gemstone at Jeb blackwat
asks question what's the difference
between rubies emeralds sapphires Etc
rubies and sapphires are the same exact
mineral the mineral is called corundum
and it is made up of aluminum and oxygen
the only difference between Ruby and
Sapphire is that the gem industry
designated the color red for rubies
every other color of the rainbow is
called Sapphire you also asked about
emeralds Emerald is a variety of the
mineral Barrel many minerals get their
colors from different Trace element
impurities this one has chromium 3+
impurities on a very Trace scale and
this one has iron impurities to make it
blue at seamster Heidi asks what's the
most unusual gemstone you've ever heard
of I need some inspiration I have a
treat for you this is a mineral sodalite
the variety name is called hackmanite
and hackmanit are very special because
they have a color property called
tenebrescence which happens when we
shine a UV light on it you'll see that
the stones are now glowing in orange
yellow color we're going to charge them
up a little bit orange stone is from mon
St hilir a very famous mine in Quebec
and the yellow stone is from Afghanistan
okay let's get the lights back on now
look at how the color of these Stones
has changed
a tiny bit of sulfur gives it this color
effect and now if we add some light to
them they'll go back to their original
colorless versions they're just
reflecting all of the light back to us
at Lee Perez Ray asks where does The
Rock Dwayne Johnson right on the Mo's
scale well Dwayne The Rock Johnson is
off the scale because he's a cool human
but his bones are actually made of Bio
appetite which is a mineral with a moose
hardness of five the mo hardness scale
is a scale that we use to compare
mineral hardness so when I say hardness
I'm actually referring to the scratch
ability of a mineral not how tough it is
the mineral talc has a moose hardness
scale of one at the Other Extreme of the
mo hardness scale diamond is number 10
the Moose hardness scale is also a
logarithmic scale which means that the
difference between 1 and two on the
scale is 10 times so so diamond is 10 *
10 * 10 * 10 and so on times harder than
the mineral talc the reason why hardness
is so important for gemstones that are
used in jewelry is that something like a
diamond is very difficult to scratch so
if you're wearing it every day in a ring
it's much less likely to turn dull over
time because it will not build up
scratches whereas diamonds are the
hardest on the Mo's hardness scale which
means scratch ability Jade is the most
difficult to break break so it is the
toughest mineral at Pete Peters 21 asks
if diamonds are the hardest substance in
the world how do they cut diamonds in
order to cut a diamond you need to use
other diamonds they would have to take a
rotating plate that we call a lap and
cover it in Diamond powder they'll start
with a very coarse grit of powder and
eventually they get to finer and finer
grits to create the polished effect this
is called the Kimberly diamond it's over
55 karats in weight and it originated
from South Africa and was gifted to the
Smithsonian in 2019 this would be a
rectangular or emerald cut you may also
refer to it as a baguette cut and it's
very special because most diamonds are
cut in a round brilliant shape which
means that it's very good at disguising
flaws light comes into the diamond
bounces around the facets and comes back
out to your eye in this case the light
light comes in it bounces a little bit
but you can see that there are no flaws
in this diamond at sakassi asks how is a
diamond's Purity graded the four C's
which stands for its color its Clarity
its cut and its carrot weight there are
many gemological institutes that can
actually give your diamond a grade
they'll look to see if it has any
inclusions or impurities in the diamond
such as another mineral that's stuck
inside of the crystal or if it has any
other flaws like a crack then they'll
look at the color when grading colorless
diamonds people tend to prefer that
there not be traces of yellow the yellow
is due to small amounts of nitrogen
substituting into the carbon structure
of the diamond crystal however if
there's a lot of nitrogen in the crystal
it will turn more of a brilliant yellow
color and that's actually considered a
good thing we call this a fancy color
Diamond they'll also look at how much it
weighs so the carrot weight which is a
fifth of a gram they'll also then judge
the cut of the stone so is it a round
brilliant is it a pear shape is it a
mares cut like an eye shape a mares cut
is an interesting cut that was more
popular in the 80s at@ kxu asks do
synthetic SL cultured diamonds also last
forever synthetic diamonds are
chemically and crystallographically
speaking the same as naturally formed
diamonds so they're also number 10 on
the mo hardness scale they have the same
Optical properties the same thermal
properties and conductivity properties
they were just not formed through
geological processes they were formed in
a laboratory unfortunately for all of us
diamonds will not last forever because
diamonds are formed at very high
pressures and temperatures so at Earth's
surface conditions they are not the
stable form of carbon graphite is the
stable mineral at surface conditions so
millions of years from now maybe even
longer your diamonds will turn into
graphite at bloodied Roman asks yo they
made Minecraft obsidian into a real
thing sorry to break it to you but
obsidian was there first here's a piece
of obsidian an obsidian is actually
natural volcanic glass so it's not a
mineral because it does not have a
crystal structure this obsidian glass
has the same chemical composition to our
Granite they were magmas that formed
underneath the surface of our planet but
this one ended up nucleating and growing
crystals whereas this one never had the
chance obsidian also has an
anthropological connection because it
was used by prehistoric humans because
it breaks very easily and forms these
conoidal fractures which can be very
sharp and they were used to make arrow
heads and other knives at rocks by K1
asks what is the biggest difference
between fool's gold and real gold this
is real gold gold is a mineral and it
has this beautiful golden color in
contrast this is called Fool's Gold the
proper name is pyate and it's composed
of iron sulfide so it's not actually
gold at all but it also has this
beautiful golden luster but if we hold
them side by side you'll see that
they're actually quite different in
color they both have the same cubic
structure for their crystal structure
this one just happened to form more edal
crystals more blocky obvious crystals
this one on an atomic scale would still
be crystallin you just can't see the
crystals with your naked eye at Kyo B
badaro asks do we theoretically know
every mineral in the universe we
currently know of over 5,000 mineral
species on our planet today as for the
whole universe I cannot say but
theoretically speaking we know that the
combinations of different elements in
the periodic table could account for
approximately 9,000 so we still have a
ways to go to keep finding those
minerals we're going to need some more
minerology in the future to help us look
for them at Ben king1 asks where do the
minerals in your mobile phone come from
there are approximately 65 elements that
are necessary to make your cell phone
run many of them are considered to be
Rare Earth elements that often times
come in what we call critical minerals
for example one of these minerals would
be called spine and this mineral happens
to have a lot of lithium in it and
lithium is going to be very important
for those lithium ion batteries we mine
spyine from rocks called pegmatites and
pegmatites are really really great at
concentrating what we call these
incompatible elements these are elements
that are either too small like lithium
or too big like uranium that they don't
like to fit in your average Crystal
structures pegmatite deposits occur
across the globe but they tend to be
concentrated in places like Brazil we
even have some pegmatites here in the
United States up in Maine or in
California at the Inspira asks what is
the most cursed Diamond historically
people love the idea of attaching a
curse or a good story to a famous
diamond and what more famous Diamond
than the Hope Diamond which resides here
at our national museum of natural
history in the early 1900s the Hope
Diamond was bought and sold many times
and all of its owners kept losing their
money in having to sell this diamond and
its last private owner Evelyn Walsh mlan
had a rather tragic life that befell her
family and herself so this idea of the
curse just kept building and building
with a Hope Diamond but today when we
think about the Hope Diamond we actually
think of it as a blessing because it has
become the Cornerstone of our national
gem collection at Phil Brown 62 asks how
do crystals form different minerals
require different temperature or
pressure conditions in order to build
their crystals they also need some kind
of fluid in order for those necessary
ingredients to get to the right place
crystals are formed of atoms and so if
you have consistent ingredients in the
case of this amethyst which is a variety
of quarts the ingredients would be
silicon and oxygen the silicon and
oxygen atoms will arrange themselves in
a repeating specific pattern in this
case it will make a hexagonal cryst
Crystal system and if you keep adding
atoms to this tessellation you will
eventually end up with a crystal that
you can see with the naked eye at Laura
oper asks are pearls considered to be
minerals since their origin is organic
pearls are technically not minerals
because they are formed through organic
processes and part of the definition of
a mineral is that it has to form
inorganically however I'm actually a
biom minerology so I do study minerals
that are formed form Med through
biological processes and in the case of
pearls what we're looking at is the
mineral aragonite or calcium carbonate
so what happens is that the organism in
this case a Pearl Oyster naturally forms
this layer of naker or mother of pearl
inside of its shell and if a piece of
debris gets stuck inside of its organism
as it's living it becomes irritated and
it tries to cover that with the same
naker that we call a pearl another
example of a bio mineral would be your
bones you are in fact a biomineralizing
organism where your bones are made up of
Bio appetite appetite is calcium
phosphate and it's also formed through
geological processes at bracer 788 asks
what does Gemmy mean we say that
something is Gemmy when someone could
potentially cut a gemstone out of it for
example this Crystal of barrel also
known as the variety Emerald is very
beautiful it's rather transparent this
gemstone could potentially be cut out of
a crystal like this because the crystal
is Gemmy in contrast this Crystal is
relatively opaque which means it would
be very difficult to cut a gemstone out
of this Crystal at Emma Teresa J asks my
friend has a moonstone parentheses
orthic ring that the Jeweler told her
she can't get wet is this true what's
behind that crystallographically SL
geochemically or is this a myth
Moonstone looks something like this if
you can get it wet it's not going to be
harmed whatsoever now the Jeweler might
have been confused with a different
thing which we call Opal Opals look
something like this and they are also
commonly used in jewelry but they're not
technically minerals Opals are
mineraloids which are almost the same as
minerals but they don't have a crystal
structure instead Opals are composed of
tiny tiny spheres made out of silica and
these spheres are packed together this
means that Opals are very porous and
they can easily absorb water so if
you're going to do your dishes maybe
take your opal ring off first at Tiffy
sniffs asks how are geodes formed and
why are they so cool well I agree that
geodes are very cool if you were to walk
around in Utah and pick up a rock that
looks something like this break it open
you might find that it's hollow inside
and that it formed a geode so geodes
form when you have an open cavity and
and this allows crystals to grow inside
of the space this one is likely filled
with the mineral called quartz or
silicon dioxide this would be your most
common geode that you would find if
you're going to crack open geodes make
sure that you wear your safety glasses
Safety First at Shelby by Lynn l asks
why does turquoise jewelry have to be so
expensive because the gemstones that
they're made from are quite rare it's
very difficult first of all for the
earth to create these amazing minerals
and to form examples of them that are
going to be large enough pretty enough
in order for someone to want to make
jewelry out of them the next part would
be someone has to mine that stone so a
miner would go to a mine such as one in
Arizona find that turquoise then it has
to go to a lapidary which is the person
that actually cuts the stones into a
cabasan which is a stone that's polished
on top and usually flat on the bottom so
it makes a dome shape and finally you
need a jeweler that's going to take that
gemstone and mount it into a piece of
jewelry now the metal that is used to
mount that piece of jewelry can be quite
expensive in and of itself especially if
it's something like gold or platinum so
together you form this rather expensive
piece of jewelry at lenoak asks where do
rubies even come from it turns out that
rubies or the mineral corundum can be
found all around the world if you are
interested in finding rubies in the
United States you could even go to North
Carolina to Ruby mines however the most
precious rubies the most sought after
rubies are from Burma there is an area
of Muk Burma that has a huge City made
up of many many thousands of people
where their entire job is to find rubies
in a mountain of marble at tales and
kitty asks what are quote blood diamonds
unfortunately minerals and gemstones
often hold a lot of value per volume
which means they're very small but
they're very very expensive and thus
they have been embroiled in conflicts
and used to trade for weapons and often
times can be directly linked to
conflicts and death ethical sourcing is
very important currently there is a
process called the Kimberly process
which can trace the origins of diamond
crystals before they get cut and sold
into jewelry so if a diamond comes into
the United States without the proper
certification from the Kimberly
committee they get confiscated by TSA
and they're actually brought here to the
Smithsonian National Museum of Natural
History so that they don't get traded
out illegally at DX play asks how do you
find your gems as the curator of gems
and minerals myself and my team go out
and Scout for new minerals that have
appeared on the market recently we
acquired a crystal of the mineral called
sapphirine not Sapphire and it was one
of my favorite Acquisitions because it
happens to be the largest crystal of
saffrin in the world and it came from a
mine in Madagascar so those are all the
questions we have today thanks for
watching Gem and Mineral
[Music]
support